okay philosophical question what is the
definition of shadows and because run
along to resolve people argument for now
but let's commute for now don't we for
now that shadows our regions that are
not visible from light sources and again
if you're on public transport or if your
board in the lecture such as this one
but hopefully not this one well you can
take a look at the shadow regions and
you will you will immediately recognize
that these are the regions that are
somehow occluded with respect to the
light source let's take a look at an
example this small red dot on the top
this is a light source this is a point
light source and this black thing is a
sphere and behind that what would
respect to the light source we have an
umbrella this is a completely shadowed
region this is the name of the
completely shadowed region and if we are
going to shade these points in your a
tracer and if I want shadows then I need
to compute whether this Ray when I am
shading the point is obstructed or
occluded from the light source or not
now this is very simple to do so imagine
that I would like to shade this point
below on the plane and what I would do
is I would send ray that I call a shadow
ray towards the light source what I'm
interested in is is it obstructed
obstructed means that it hits something
before it's blocked by something so the
first question is is an incredibly
difficult question is this obstructed or
not this is first-rate it is obstructed
indeed okay what about this guy here
then
this is obstructed as well okay what
about these guys
these these guys are good okay cool so
it is for now very simple concept
shadows it means that I will also have a
visibility signal that I multiply the
intensity with and this is
obviously the rail either hits an object
or it doesn't that's it so very simple
this intensity that is not radiant but
this is the hack that we use in ray
tracing this is the simpler version of
things still I am going to set to zero
whatever shading I have at that point I
don't care it is in shadows it's going
to be completely black so this is the
simpler version what about real life
well in real life point light sources
don't exist because the point by
mathematical definition is of measure
zero it means that is infinitely small
and something that is infinitely small
well we call it a light source so this
is something as infinitely small but it
has a given amount of energy well if you
are asked Stephen Hawking he would say
that this is a definition of a black
hole so we would have a black hole and
if this would happen we would have much
bigger problems than computing shadow
rays so that's definitely out of our
interest at the moment so we have an
earlier light source and we still have
the Umbra because none of the Rays make
it to the light source but we have a
different region that we call penumbra
which are partially shadowed regions so
things are going to get much more
interesting now I'm going to shoot to
shadow rays from the surface towards
different regions of the land source
what about these guys what about the
right shadow ray so good in salute okay
what about the LAT
it's not a little okay excellent so this
is this already doesn't seem binary
anymore and this visibility single X is
going to be continuous so there may be
points which are visible from some part
of the light source but not visible from
another part of the light source and
therefore we have some kind of
solution and the question is how do we
compute this how can we write a program
that can give me a beautiful and Umbra
and not just hard shadows so if we only
have the Umbra this is in the literature
this is called hard shadows and penumbra
is soft shadows we're going to see
examples of that in a second so very
simple let's try to approximate the area
of the light source that is visible from
that point over the whole area of the
light source let's see an example of
that but first I'm interested in how to
approximate this because I'm talking
about arrows and this sounds like some
kind of integration problem and for now
we are not going to live out here
integrals over this for instance what we
can do is we could shoot a lot of shadow
rays and try to approximate this area so
the approximation is going to be the
following I'm interested in the physical
shadow Ray's the number of visible
shadow Ray's over all the shadow rays
that I have computed well example how is
this region going to look like well I'm
going to shoot 100 shadow Ray's from
these small black dots and I'm
interested in how many of them is going
to make it to the light source what do
you think well out of 100 calories does
100 hinder light source unobstructed
definitely not what about 50 probably
not okay well it's actually it's quite
reasonably dark there so let's say that
three of them is the light source it's
very simple approximation I shoot 100
shadow Ray's three of them in turn
therefore this is what I'm going to
multiply this intensity
have computed with okay what about the
next region this is a bit far away out
of 100 does 100 of them hit this region
definitely not
half of them what do you think our first
time definitely okay cool and if we go
even more out of the Umbra then I have
this white dot and I'm interested in how
many of these could hit the light source
well I think that that can be there are
regions where these are definitely
attracted but it's not too much so let's
say that 95% of the shadow is hit the
light source so I can already compute in
a way soft shadows not only shadows but
now soft shadows you're going to see
examples of that and what we have done
here is actually Monte Carlo integration
and you're going to hear a lot about
Monte Carlo integration it's in every
list and under some teenage people look
up the top ten build list of the best
music clips of Lady gaga
and the others and what I do myself
I confess I look up the top ten
mathematical techniques nowadays and I
tell you that Monte Carlo integration is
always on the Billboard top list it's
one of the most effective techniques to
evaluate integrals and we are going to
study them extensively and it's going to
make your life infinitely simple now a
quick bonus question is can such an
image be physically correct well
obviously it's a drawing so it's not
correct but there is something that's
unbelievably so incorrect that it would
it would need some attention who can
tell me that yes
that is true but unfortunately this is a
mind-reading exercise so you have to
figure out what I have taught I'm just
kidding that's absolutely true what that
people him yes
he's down well as far as I know physics
the lab should spend a little bit
inwards from the black object but that's
a problem of the T we are very far away
from that
correctness but you're absolutely true
so if I say in terms of shadows wait I
would have said something about the
shadows of their shadows any way
well the shadows between the object and
the crime like yes okay what's what's up
with everyone you should have written
that error wouldn't technically be
shadowed itself which arrow and the area
the error is one more none of the the
air part between the object and put it's
at this no and I don't understand any of
this in our area between the surface
with the object it says empty space
which is yeah under your fingers from
instance what about if I ask about this
transition from here to the outside so
if you imagine these dots that we have
if I will put it in the Umbra and I will
slowly move out of there
will I experience such a jump that I see
here okay why not
because if I start from the Umbra it may
be that yes
I cannot construct any kind of ray that
hits the light source and as I move
outwards it will continuously increase
this probability there is not going to
be a jump that you see this abrupt color
change it is going to be a perfectly
smooth gradient or almost a perfectly
smooth gradient depending on many other
physical properties but this is more or
less what I would see and there's going
to be an example of that in a second so
this is what I have said for those who
are reading this at home and the
question is very simple question what
kind of light source do we have on this
image it's a point light source
excellent why because I don't see my
child
excellent so this should be a point
light source and well technically you
could say that if you have a smaller
area light source but only one shadow
Ray's so you don't do this integration
just on one side you can have something
similar to this but generally these are
point light sources what about these
guys
you have one's own good
the left one seems to be a point light
source the right one I can see this
beautiful continuous change and this is
definitely a penumbra but if I take a
look at this region below this object
then I can also see some kind of
penumbra so it might be that this is a
small on the left it's a small area
light source that is close to the object
perhaps and this is why I don't see the
penumbra but other places I see it and
here my writing has a really pronounced
effect so this is definitely an area
light source well the next question is
that in physical reality we usually
don't see perfectly black shadows so if
I take a look around in this room I see
shadows I see
there the region that is missed and then
sometime you run and little brush
something but this is anything but
perfectly Galactica's grizzle prove
offices over you know some reflections
will never of yes that's true so there
is an effect that we are going to talk
about next lecture and it is called
indirect illumination and this basically
is that in an interesting program we are
only accounting for the direct effect of
an odd source but in physical reality it
is possible that the light comes in
through this window hits the wall first
this wide wall and then hits the ground
in this Panama region and then it goes
converse Maya and therefore some of the
energy is going to be picked up so the
effect of this white wall is going to
make these black or dark shadows lighter
and this we cannot compute yet this is
multiple diffused bounces after each
other we cannot take this into account
we would need to serve the full
rendering equation for this so what we
have is direct illumination and this is
where the ambient term comes into place
what we have been talking about this
ambient term is just basically adding
something to this intensity that I have
why because this was uptick in each of
it so I would have perfectly black
shadows and for instance for this
classroom I would have an ambient
intensity that is a color that is
greyish and therefore these regions
would not be perfectly black but I need
at least six great numbers and therefore
it would be a bit more gray so this is a
hacky this is a really crude
approximation of indirect illumination
but more or less works at least it is an
accepted way to cheat back this last
energy in a ray tracer yes every
question of for the
Monte Carlo technique shuttle casting a
shadow race ahead how how do we
determine where at the surface of the
night where you're shooting the points
because there's a surface how do we pick
some random points on the Soyuz these
are the difficult details of ray tracing
power programs there are techniques that
help you to pick a uniformly chosen
random direction on a sphere for
instance that I would shoot or uniform
directions or points so I choose a
random point on the sphere and I'm going
to connect this to that other point and
so perfectly uniformly chosen random
points this I need to generate on the
surface of the light source and this I
would need to sample and there's also
optimizations for that because what if a
light source has non uniform radiation
so some light sources are really intense
in one direction but not in others how
do i account for that and that is even
optimization techniques for that and the
short beauty break while we like let's
render a lot and but it seems that
apparently some nerds are living their
dreams in our program and creating
people like that there is lots of
programs that help you achieving these
realistic things and and later on we
will talk a bit about how skin realistic
skin can be achieved such as the one
that you can see here because skin is
not a surface skin is a volume so not
everyone knows but some amount of the
light is penetrating the surface of the
skin and it goes believe it gets scared
and the storm maybe even a thousand
times there and it may come out
somewhere else from your skin and this
is why the wonder computer games in the
older computer games this is why humans
really fake and plastic because they
don't account for this effect and the
newest computer games can compute this
or something like this in
and this is what makes them so beautiful